music can really set a mood a little
classical or jazz might relax your whole
body while Papa rock music can get your
blood pumping for a night out on the
town but if music can seemingly enhance
a mindset or help you resist mental
fatigue can also affect athletic
performance
the term synchronous music refers to op
tempo songs with a strong beat that
coincide with the repetitive movements
of a sport and it's this type of music
that leads to a higher work output in
athletes particularly in sports that
involve endurance with rhythmic or
repetitive movements such as
cross-country skiing this is put into
practice as Haile Gebrselassie famously
synchronized his running stride to the
rhythmical pop song scatman when
breaking the 10,000 meter world record
studies show that music can act as both
a cognitive and physical stimulant
especially when the music has a personal
meaning to the individual for athletes
who suffer from pre-competition anxiety
music can be used to enhance mood
self-esteem and confidence even during
competition music and narrow an
athlete's attention diverting focus away
from sensations of fatigue in studies of
athletes using music those who listen to
pop songs during training or warm-ups
had higher heart rates and increased
muscle power compared to those who
trained without music furthermore
because music can trigger emotion it was
documented to enhance mental imagery a
technique in which athletes picture
themselves mastering a sport before
competition this state of mind is
crucial for all athletes particularly
before major events funny enough coaches
even withhold music from athletes
sometimes as a motivational tool
athletes are told they can use music
during training sessions only once they
have reached a specific productivity
level so which music works best
almost all findings found that listening
to music period regardless of
composition or speed enhanced
performance compared to no music however
music with an upbeat tempo of greater
than 120 beats per minute yielded the
greatest improvements science says make
a pumpup playlist full of your favorite
upbeat songs of the time and blast the
competition away don't forget we have a
new video out every day during the
Olympics can't wait our amazing partners
at the CBC already have 5 of the videos
up now for you to binge on just head to
CBC CA slash Olympics slash sign says to
watch them before anyone else link in
the description but we also want to know
your questions for this special series
use the hashtag
science says and let us know you're
burning Olympic questions and subscribe
for more awesome science videos